[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 144 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm Mok Madol and as always I'm here
with my colleague Melanie Moore how you
doing Melanie I'm good mark and I'm here
we're both here we're here SOTA here I'm
at home you're in the office it's fine
all right
well mark this week we are going to
speak with teri and Tai Chi from Akari
it's another episode that we recorded
while we were at next and we were really
glad to get them to come in and talk to
us about their e-commerce platform that
operates out of Japan yeah the US and
the UK and the story that they have
around you're working with micro
services as well as migrating services
on to GCP excellent and as for always
will have cool things of the week and
our questions of the week and the
question of the week will be how do I
use my existing identity management
system with Google cloud platform that's
a great question as you mentioned though
we're going to start out with cool
things of the week and one of them is a
github repo from Sarah Robinson from our
team she did a repo that basically helps
demo auto ml and the integration with
firebase storage so if you wanted to
experiment with querying a custom auto
ml model from a web app you can look at
her example this actually uses some of
the data that she also did an example on
earlier in the year when we talked about
it during episode 108 and we also talked
about Auto ml at that time notice
another auto ml point that we wanted to
cover is that there's this article and
it steps through putting together an
example of Auto ml using data to help
classify graffiti artists yeah it's
really cool it goes through basically
how they used auto mo to take a bunch of
data and sort of align it with
particular artists as well as how they
improved it once they built it as well
which is kind of nice yes and then
another cool thing of the week we also
want to mention Colt McAnlis who's
another one of our teammates and he has
recently published another performance
Atlas videos great video series as he's
been putting out there in this one he
says he is helping cryptocurrency fans
with their datastore transactions
hitting the buzz words he's hitting the
buzz way he's totally hitting the buzz
words it wouldn't be a podcast episode
if I didn't talk about kubernetes so I'm
really excited about this too so
there's a blog post discussing basically
deploying only what you trust
introducing binary authorization for
google crouppen Eddy's engine basically
this is all about how do I trust what is
running on my production infrastructure
so making sure that only the things that
you want to have running on your creep
and Eddie's clusters are the things that
are running on that kubernetes cluster I
mean this could be a whole episode in it
to itself but there's a couple of really
cool things in there
they have image and repository
whitelisting is a great way of basically
saying here are the things that the
image is that you can send using
matching scripts to be able to do that
but also signature verification for pod
generation - I'm ways to do that what
does that mean what does that mean
basically they they verify signatures
against the images that are running
against the container analysis API but
there's also open-source ways of doing
this - it goes into all the details it's
really really nice I like this article a
lot and there's some nice animated
visuals in there as well yeah so whoever
wrote the blog post that looks like he's
changing Sandra Crowell if I'm
pronouncing that even vaguely right nice
job on the on the diagrams alright mark
I think it's time for us to go speak
with Tai Chi and Thierry sounds good
let's go do it we are happy to have with
us today
teri Lee and Tai Chi Nakashima who are
both from Macari and we are grateful
that you guys were able to join us here
at next thanks for coming great thank
you good to be here
so Terry can you tell us a little bit
about yourself and what you do at
Meharry I'm a engineer at Murray current
we are working on this micro service
chain to migrate our back-end from a
monolithic infrastructure to micro
service architecture so we are actually
just starting on that and thaisa here is
building that platform - you know Rho
micro services and I'm on a team that's
trying to rewrite the backend into micro
services that's running on that platform
great
alright so tai chi outside of what terry
is already shared what's your background
so I'm so standing here Microsoft
Spartan team I'm building the platform
top on the
the contest engine so that back in the
engineer act Eddie - easily - deployed
on micro-service great so actually if
you're people who aren't familiar with
Macari what is it what does it do so
mercury is C - C marketplace so user can
save their stuff on our market Chris and
buy it from their smartphone and
originally it's based in Japan
yes it's Bissinger but it's also
accessible in the US yes we have
millions of users in the US
yeah it's gonna say can you share like
any like how big is the platform like
how many people use Macario didn't broad
sense at least we have like millions of
daily active users in Japan it's like a
huge thing in Japan to like sell your
used books and stuff we're not that big
in the US but we are so we also already
have like tens of millions downloads
already so it's growing very fast and
we're exact we're very excited to say
how it's going in the coming years nice
and what are some of the other markets
that you're in we also have b.a.p in the
UK and what are some of the things that
people could sell out its kind of
everything in Japan recently started
doing even like cars and stuff
complicated that's really interesting so
have you always been on Google cloud or
did you migrate from somewhere else so
all the Marikana is running on the on
premise in Japanese provider so we are
trying to migrate from on-premise to the
should be brought home right and you
specifically I think you said as well
you said specifically you're working on
gke or kubernetes engine as the platform
doing that can you tell us a bit more
about how that's going his team actually
started working on that platform that
utilizes gke and other GCP products to
you know allow us to develop services on
that platform so on my team we are
trying to deploy new micro services into
that platform so far it's been going
well I'd say we have a couple services
running on it it allows the developers
to you know iterate on their services in
a much faster speed without relying on
you know SRE team to deploy if their
code for them great what made you decide
to use GK so we want deploys the
application as a container because in
micro service world each sub stream
should have the freedom to choose to or
a software programming language so
infrastructure point of view so if it's
everything it's part as a container it's
easy to handle because we don't need
take care about the application is
beating Ruby or Python or ball so we
want to use a container so as a for
deploying the container
I think the currently the best juice is
a kubernetes and the best management
services UK so that's why we chose that
again did you have any challenges with
implementing gke challenges on GK or
Cabana tests we can do anything so for
example if we don't use namespace so
every singles the default namespace in
that it's getting the complex yep
everything needs one namespace so we
need setup securio namespace for each
micro sub says also we need provides a
proper authorization to the each micro
service team so we need to set up some
arbok and this stuff is challenging
point for us yeah do you automate any of
that like do you do like a continuous
integration like it sounds like if
you're you're nodding at me so I'm gonna
go with you're probably doing that kind
of stuff yeah
use a lot of tools to automate that for
example we never actually go to
disappear um so to actually activate you
know by clicking a button or use
terraform to you know define what we
need where you spinning her to actually
deploy our to tailor to gke yeah things
like that well great so what are some
upcoming products that you're excited
about in regards to the current platform
that you've built or your current setup
I'm excited about Jackie on pram that
you have just announced because we
actually had some challenges you know
interacting between our own pram data
center - with the services in GAE and
having to deploy some service into
Kaylee and its maintain some legacy
system in the comp ramp that the center
is kind of a burden so if we have Jackie
on pram you know we could deploy all
that micro services both in you know
chicane and in the data center so that
the members can focus on their business
logic and the deploy can be done to both
sides that's really cool I'd love to go
back to what you're talking about before
as well you're talking about sort of
using spinnaker and that kind of stuff I
think for people who are potentially
thinking about like CI CD pipelines how
have you found that experience using
spinnaker show you something for testing
as well like how does that normally look
inside what you fill so that reason to
choose that Spinnaker's in micro service
each
back-end service engineer need to handle
deployed they're safe right
so in manjar is maybe central operation
team is doing this stuff but micro
services each team need to do this so we
need some way to easily set up
deployment pipeline and in CTL if you
learn capacitive apply we can deploy but
if just capacity it does not make sure
the deployment is worked or not so
because of some resource quota shortage
maybe deployment may fail but if only to
be CTL it's difficult to fund deployment
its way we need to check by capacity
describe what it discman so that's why
Vince on the special tool for deployment
and we found the spinnaker is easy to
create deployment pipeline and it also
checks the capacity apply each box or
not
the primate where it's playing pipeline
so that's why we chose spinnaker for
deployment
so do your developers have like a
specific place they have to like put
code like if I'm a developer working on
Macari and I'm like I burped some code
how do spinnaker find it and like how
does that flow look we use github to you
know manage our code and so every toe
change goes to github they were open you
know full request they can configure
their CEO tool to build their image for
that PR and their image will be pushed
to GCR and the spinnaker has the ability
to you know listen to a repository and
find the you know images defined by you
know some regular expression so it can
automatically find the image that's
updated for this application and you can
choose to automatically deploy that
image to chicken in the pipeline that
you have is there anything you wish
someone would build that would make it
easier there's one interesting sorry
about you know having that ability to
you know just make spinnaker listen to
some repository and deploy stuff it used
to be not working right and then
starting from one day I think a few
months ago he suddenly started working
so it automatically built all the images
in that repository to the cluster so it
is trying to deploy like all the
historical versions of all services that
that works terrible but it's fine now
you sorted it out now it's fine
and the currently everything needs to be
configured by a GUI so we won't manage
the pipeline in code so that it's easy
to manage we can debut changes so this
is what we want that's what you need
yes that's good to know we're doing this
at next outside of seeing me on Prem for
gke what else have you seen that you've
been excited about I'm excited about the
auto ml stuff I'm not an expert on
machine learning but I used to play with
it and I spent a lot of time you know
trying to build a super model and seeing
that being automated and seeing like I
can train a model in like 2 clicks I
think it will save a lot of effort for
many machinery engineers and I think you
know also like allow people from like
business intelligence team to be able to
you know and analyze our log and
automatically find interesting
conclusions of our you know user
behaviors which is exciting to me and to
the team I guess so do you have certain
ways and right now that come to mind on
how you'd want to implement it once it's
made available
I can easily imagine because our logs
are already in bakery and I saw a demo
of building models based on bigquery
data I can imagine like people without
machine learning skill easily like do
make user classification or some you
know analyze some user behavior based on
the ultramen technology based on your
specific experiences with your user base
in the content that you have on your
users yeah that would be wonderful
especially in terms of being able to
specialize your interactions with them I
know that's a that's a leading need for
many customers out there right you what
it would have you happened to say that
you've been particularly excited about
I'm excited about cloud service platform
CSP I don't know that exactly what it is
but I saw the line about the old manager
is do for micro service brought home I
think that still will be the key
technology so I want to use SEO so yes
this is very valuable for being able to
track especially with so many systems
and distributed yeah we're tracking
health performance is happening so I'd
love to take our back to and hear more
about how your migration is going
because it sounds like you've gone from
unpromoted a--the to cloud micro
services in one go is that accurate or
how's that journey being we started
doing it and we
have deployed some services on jke but
the majority of the back end is still in
our data center and we'll probably take
some much longer time to do that how
have you been
tearing it apart like you just like what
are you doing there how's that working
we try to find the most important or the
most fundamental services like user
services and like items services for us
and item means something that a user try
to sell like finding these most
fundamental services and make them as
micro services so that you know some
other team can when they need a new
feature they can utilize these services
to build new features so we start from
there and we'll try to move as much as
the system to take a yes as possible and
why are you doing this I think we are at
a point where we have more than 100
engineers working on the same repository
and it's like half million lines of code
to make a simple code change to modify
some part of the feature you have to
deploy the whole thing and you know
fingers crossed nothing breaks it's
never right exactly so I think that's
the main reason you know to make our
organization more scalable why'd the
cloud because you could do micro
services on your own hardware why you
come into the cloud there isn't the
crowd so as I said before each developer
need to operate their service it's same
as they also need to operate database
itself so
we won't manage everything in on premise
is super hard for normal developers if
we use a crowd they have use who API and
developer easily to set up the database
these manage services so that's why we
need move to the crowd nuts how are you
controlling what developers are able to
do what you just like they can do
anything it's fine you're being a bit
more restrictive as they say we use the
traffic to set up cloud services so
currently we manage full telephone
configuration in one repository we
prepare directory for each
micro-services and each Microsoft's team
try to send a pull request to this
directory and the micro service proton
team is always debuted at call and we
check the developer does not do the very
strange stuff so we try to limit that
way you've already talked a little bit
about this in terms of the value of
having micro services but if you were to
do this all over again like tips ideas
lessons learned that you'd recommend
start from the cloud
don't make any money
I mean we started five years ago my
colleagues started five years ago they
probably didn't have the option to start
from what we have here that's why we're
doing things which is which is common
yeah but there are definitely lots of
people who are in similar situations so
if you were like this is the best way
we've worked out to be like this is how
we do the conversion of micro services
or like don't do it this way what would
you recommend I feel like we are trying
to make too many changes at the same
time like we are trying to rewrite the
code from HP with goal and we're trying
to deploy our services from you know I'm
from DC to the cloud and we are trying
to micro the data base from there to the
cloud as well you know the design is
from a monolithic web app to micro
service architectures so we're trying to
make so many changes I think the
difficulty explodes and sometimes make
things more difficult than it should be
before we let you both go anything else
that you wanted to share any places that
people can find more information about
Merrick Ari outside of the website we
have engineering
it's mostly in Japanese those hey that's
okay but we have English version yeah
Google Translate it's fine yeah well
we'll point everybody to that but yeah
this is great so well we'll make sure to
get the links from you and share that in
the show notes
absolutely what sort of stuff do you
cover in the engineering blog I'd loved
it like look no more the kind of
technical stack we use to the life
engineer and what is engineer manager
like organizational things also to like
sort of un sweetie we do many events in
Japan so every time we're doing we also
announce a new power plant what are some
resources that you like to go to for
help with some of the building up the
stack that you have
I always listen this podcast I always
start from Google Google my problem is
in the right place yeah thanks cool well
thank you I appreciate both of you
joining and thanks for sharing all your
insights thank you thank you for you
ideas yeah thanks thanks great thank you
thank you again Taichi and Terry for
coming on to the podcast while we were
at next yeah really great episode and
thanks for sharing your journey as well
from building a monolithic application
and then transferring that over to micro
services and how that's going and all
the lessons you learned along the ways
as well all right mark how do I use my
existing identity management system with
Google cloud platform yeah that is
actually a really interesting question
to I didn't even realize this was the
thing really so basically by default
Google cloud is tied to Google accounts
that's kind of how it was built but you
may have your own identity management
system maybe you use LDAP or probably
some other things that I'm not even
aware of and you may want to use that
instead or basically integrated with
Google cloud so that you don't have to
reinvent the wheel essentially which i
think is really cool so there's an
article that we will link to will give
you sort of the top-level highlights
here that I think are most important but
the great thing is is you can do this so
if you have an existing identity
management system you can integrate this
thing there are set of prerequisites to
getting started you need to identify a
domain that you'll use to set up your
cloud identity account you'll need to
make sure that you have someone who can
make text or cname changes to your DNS
settings and also to allow your users to
authenticate against your identity
system you'll need to implement a Cemil
single sign-on we'll talk about a little
bit about that too so you can do those
three things you can configure the
ability to use third-party identity
management a couple other things we want
to mention from the article as well is
that they recommend doing a proof of
concept to basically you know don't
synchronize everything all at once
try synchronizing a small number of
users or a small group and experiment
with that first to make sure that your
criteria and your configuration is
properly set before you do
synchronization they also mention you
know you don't need to necessarily map
your entire organization it's it's
important to a plan what you really need
to synchronize and then go from there
you know they do have some pointers
around mapping out the functional roles
for your users and creating groups to
map to those roles you know grant roles
to a Google group instead of to
individual users when possible because
it's easier to add and remove members
from a group than it is to update the
you know iam policy itself so those are
some tips and they also do not default
transfer passwords they will do the
transfer of the users but the passwords
themselves are not necessarily synced up
on default and it's worth noting that
there are two different ways of doing
the synchronization there's Google cloud
directory sync which will sync on a
schedule but then you can also have
third PI identity providers do a direct
connection as well each kind of has its
pros and cons depending on what systems
you already have set up how easy it is
to use their party or whether you just
want to do regular syncs on a regular
basis but you can look at both options
as well and you know the main thing to
notice that I know it's difficult to
spend time when you've got so many other
things going on
to think about Identity Management but
it's really crucial and it's useful and
it's important and resources like this
are helpful and trying to make it a
little easier for you awesome well
Melanie I know you're running off to the
airport at some point soon I know I'm
running off for the Apple at some point
soon what are you up to where are you
going what are you doing I'm just doing
some training this week but where are
you going to be mark we're so when this
comes out I will still be at PAX dev and
then I'll be hanging out of hacks West
for a good chunk of the rest of the week
after those listeners who don't know
what is pax pax is an 80,000 strong
gamer cumference
impacts West is this is the big pax
conference this several days before is
pax dev which is a game developer
conference so everyone gets together
talks about making games I'll be talking
about it going is it should be fun a
couple weeks after that I will be up at
Japan next also talking about games and
iguanas and chatting with a bunch of
customers and stuff so they'll be fun
first time in Tokyo so I'm quite excited
that's your first time in Tokyo my first
time yeah well for me in September I'm
going to be in Stellenbosch yes which is
outside of Cape Town and I
going to be at deep learning in dhaba
it's a conference on machine learning
and the plan is for me to do a couple of
interviews for the podcast out of
Stellenbosch and then after that mark
you and I are going to be at Strange
Loop where we will also be doing another
podcast recording that I'm looking
forward to awesome well Melanie thank
you for joining me on the podcast once
again this week thank you Mark and thank
you all for listening and we'll see you
all next week
[Music]
[Music]